I shower here I am worried to bring
David at home because my family is poor
and I don't want to scare David away
girl if you can scare him away
he's not for you David meets Sheila's
family for the first time and because
he's deaf and they don't know sign
language it's a bit awkward but more
than anything David is heartbroken to
see how his girlfriend's been living I
know it's the first time to sleep in the
floor
I will do my best to sleep here and over
about it
on top of showing David decide to her
life Sheila also faces feelings of
jealousy over someone that's there to
help her I don't know why when she why
he's using the young one
yeah
yeah let's talk about it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia let's
Dive Right In now I've never done a
recap on David and Sheila before but
this week they piqued my interest
starting from the top are you ready to
meet my parents later
foreign
have been dating for two years virtually
they recently met in person David is
deaf and mute and Sheila barely knows
any sign language so they rely on
writing messages on the phone to
communicate the majority of the time
which I'm sure takes a lot of patience
on both ends at this point in the season
David has been in the Philippines for a
few days with Sheila but they were
staying at a hotel now they're headed
back to Sheila's home where they will be
staying for a few days David is also set
to meet Sheila's family and her son and
Sheila admits all of this has her
nervous I am worried to bring David at
home because my family is poor and I
don't want to scare David away Wow have
you ever been ashamed to show your
partner a certain side to your life
maybe it's your living situation your
debt your toxic family yeah that's not a
good feeling but I'm glad that despite
her feeling nervous about it she's found
enough courage to move forward with
showing David the real her I try to
remind myself of the fact that if
someone is meant to be in my life they
will accept All of Me including what I
think are my imperfections because my
Pros definitely outweigh my cons and if
you can't see that
Deuces I appreciate Sheila for being
honest about her feelings though
before they head to her parents house
they meet an ASL interpreter who's going
to help David communicate with Sheila's
family my son name is this I do
interpreting
it's really easier if she's with us
rather than using our phones oh wait
look at Sheila's body language you can
tell she is not feeling this woman being
with them and communicating with her man
better than she can
interpreter it's not difficult to me
because she is good to sign than me
she's young and I feel a little jealousy
honestly for me
I would like to find an interpreter with
a man not a girl
yeah see jealousy can make you a little
irrational because the whole point of
any interpreter being there male or
female is to help her man communicate
with her family better so they can
become closer
but
I get it jealousy is one of those icky
emotions that will have you focusing on
the wrong thing and no one chooses to
feel it but to be real it's natural and
I'm not talking about being a hater
being a hater is when you feed jealousy
now that is a dangerous game but
feelings of Jealousy on their own
just normal when I see them communicate
and she look with my boyfriend and David
look on her and me I was
oh
that's cool
I'm jealous oh again at least she's
being honest with herself about it you
know I've learned the more you start to
understand yourself and why you get
jealous over certain things or certain
people
the less you'll be triggered we as
humans have to learn to look at jealousy
as a tool a messenger that's trying to
help us realize our true desires or help
us figure out what's missing in our own
lives
it's not even about the other person if
Sheila was to look at her situation
objectively and take the other woman out
of it her jealousy is just proof that
she really wants to know sign language
and get to know her partner better now
if she's smart instead of being jealous
of homegirl she would ask her for help
can you teach me Sheila only knows a
very few signs
if I love someone and been dating for
two years
I would definitely learn his language
for me when I learned how to sign it
took me a month it sounds like the ideal
teacher to me I don't know why when she
why he's using the young one it's hard
to believe this after you've been hurt
but every person isn't always a threat
you know I'm afraid what if David wants
to go with her not me do you need to
talk to David about this
no I I I don't want to show him
why not I can't
because I don't want me and David
fighting
[Music]
fast forward they make it to Sheila's
home and David describes what he sees as
shanties and extreme poverty he says
there is sewage water running everywhere
and it smells like urine and feces which
makes him really sad
David meets Sheila's dad and then she
takes him to where he will bathe I
shower
here
okay we will try tomorrow
Sheila takes David upstairs to meet her
mother who also seems to be hearing
impaired
hmm
this is my mom
David other than that oh
um nice meeting okay I don't know nice
meeting you
uh
nice meeting you too David goes on to
ask Sheila how long she's been living
there
[Music]
look The Interpreter is in shock and so
is David he can't even hide it on his
face
oh nice
Baguio
Sheila admits she's a little concerned
that after David sees how she's living
he'll only think she wants him for his
money but he doesn't seem to be worried
about that if anything he wants to do
what he can to help
David says he expected the house to have
some damage but this is worse than he
imagined he goes on to say he's worried
about staying there because there are
mosquitoes and he has nowhere to brush
his teeth before they go to bed David
Goes downstairs to have a sit-down
conversation with Sheila's dad and her
son it's a bit awkward to say the least
foreign
told you
awkward she laughs her dad if he's okay
with David being deaf and he says he's
not sure because it's difficult to talk
to him her son also seems to be
nonchalant about David although he was
grateful for the gift that David brought
him
[Music]
foreign
meeting turned out to be a
disappointment I want David to like my
family but they're acting strange
because he's deaf and now she's worried
that David won't propose to her if he
can't connect with her family
foreign she and David go on to head
upstairs to go to bed where they prepare
to sleep on the floor at this point
David is putting a lot of trust in
Sheila think about it he's in a foreign
land he knows nothing about the
environment he's in or who's living next
to them and he can't hear I'm sure he's
scared but he's managing to hold it all
together I know it's the first time to
sleep in the floor
[Music]
do my best to sleep here and over about
it
[Music]
sweet dreams
the episode ends with David saying he
wishes Sheila had more faith in him and
told him more about her life and culture
beforehand because they are quote in
this together oh that's sweet see if
they are for you you can't scare them
away
wait
let me not speak too soon because I
don't know what's in store for these two
but as of right now David
's looking like a real one and we will
definitely see after next week it's
looking like he's going to have to
support Sheila as she Grieves
[Music]
wow I guess we'll see who died next
episode
I hate to leave things off on that note
so I'll say this I love you I appreciate
you let's work on being more grateful
for what we have this week okay okay all
right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with E.T because we are covering
it all I will see you next time